This has been a bit very tedious,
especially being able to do it and every thing that
goes out of place, you already know what is going to happen, so
please enjoy contributing to us
beautifully.
proud to
be Peruvian clowns
[Applause]
a small note, comrades, a
small note, comrades,
let's go out, let's go out,
give ourselves the security, the
police security
The police souvenir is already
waiting for us outside, yes, we are going
to go out and I'll go  to ask all the
colleagues their
families the people who have come
Thank you to all the cheerleaders who are
here with us to all the
real dancers thank you for joining us but I am
going to ask everyone, without exception, as a favor
that
we are in  order at all times no the
fact of painting our faces the fact
of being a clown does not mean that we are going to
be windy or scandalous yes We
have to be funny but greeting
people Ok we have to do we have to be
funny not to make ourselves into the  funny
please what I'm telling you is very important
for the order there on the
tour yes let's always greet the audience with a
smile to the children that for
this reason we
characterize each character that
we carry I need the order and the
[Applause]
[  Applause]
you know what is beautiful You know what is
beautiful that I come from the southern zone and there
are only the beautiful people from
Thank you, thank you very much for coming, there
is one of my teachers from Gran
Clavito. Thank you, Miss Jimena,
please come here.  They tell me why not We
see the part applause for her please
applause Hey Miss Jimena is she is
please she is the administrator of this park
of this wonderful park of La Muralla
and this other thing she is going to accompany us
throughout the development of the event  because it
is part of the table
welcome welcome thank you thank you
we are presenting the Jury so that they
are already there they are already The
rest are also arriving we
are going to call an emblematic clown
loved by all of us for me the
last clown of the golden age in the
circus Tony parsley the great chanca
applause
thank you for coming Thank you for always
being present and just thanking you
And may you continue forward despite everything
that has happened strong applause for
yourselves I
love you very much another person who
is with us accompanying us if it
suits us  To accompany it, it is a pleasure for me
to introduce him because he is a tremendous clown
with a totally impeccable career,
ladies and gentlemen, I think that
this review does not need much because
everyone knows him, knows about his
career, the great one, laughter, applause, thank you,
thank you,
the goal of being able to celebrate was achieved.
together this day
as tradition has been doing
throughout this time that
Peruvian Palace Day is celebrated. Here we are
and all of us who really love
our profession are here. Thank you very much and
enjoy our day
bravo bravo
I forgot something Sorry for someone who ca
n't  stop buying
my parsley where I started where
all the clowns had the
opportunity to be there he
always gave work to any clown The
only thing I would like to ask is to
represent five shades of parsley
and ask for a loud applause for José
Álvarez
a  strong applause for him
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen We also have
another, a very beautiful character who has
been characterized, the
truth is I think she is for me, I don't know if for
you the best cosplay in Peru She
is the visit Angelica applause for her
for  Of course he accompanies us and is going to
honor us at the Jury table with
loud applause for
[Applause]
Well I tell you that today I am going to be
very demanding if I see a
bad mushroom out there, Luis,
don't think that you are going to have more meetings
like this  Let's enjoy a lot today, let
the clowns live
[Music]
Here we come, let's start now In
ten minutes guys, a moment
Hello, how are you guys, happy day
Welcome back just to
remind you of something small, let's just
try to enjoy our parade, have a good time,
have fun, let's save the
order that is very important and if
possible let's avoid taking out the cell phone
please There are specific people who are
taking photos then you can
have it and let's enjoy it let's move forward so that
people can see us so that they can enjoy us and
we can also enjoy them
arriving at La Muralla park  We
take photos, videos and everything
you want. So also take good care of
the children who are going to accompany us
today, just kids to enjoy the
party
Ok Ok Ok something more than just saying papayita ah
about the order please we
want to emphasize  at all times
suddenly we are going to become a little hateful
with this but we are going to demand
order from all our colleagues and
behavior in the streets. Yes,
please, this one, I think that when
we arrive I
told him that please, it is very
Behavior in the streets is important. The
moment we are back at
La Muralla Park, take out our cell phones,
transmit, take photos. Enjoy the
exhibition show that is going to take place. There will
be some awards in some
categories that were announced in the
advertising. You already saw with the  flyer now
yes our friend balloon is going to announce
the categories
Hello Hello How are you friends How are you
Happy Peruvian Clown Day
well as part of the team of
hosts we will be attentive to
all of you do you have any
peculiarities any doubts no don't be
afraid to approach make an eye  the
questions we are here to serve you OK And we
are also going to be on the lookout for the
clowns who suddenly come out
of the pile they go there so that we all
stay together friends this
is a special occasion that we
wanted to achieve for all of you and  I think we
should all collaborate because we are
a team in general. Okay,
today we are going to rate all the people
who have come in costume and
makeup. First, we have the
best makeup and costumes category. Ok, then we
have the
featured clown category, which is the
clown who, for example, is always there.  in
character who is always out there
making joy, encouraging the
groups and all that then we have the
clown character those who have been
impersonating some character out there I have
seen Mario I have seen little mushrooms I have
seen Mariachis and all the characters
that have been  created Here we are also going to
give awards, then we have for the
delegations that have come, for
example, there are the friends of payapé
who have come there with their banner, a
round of applause for the friends of peñapé who have
also had their banner, we
are also going to rate the best
delegation and  also as the last
category for the best banner they have
brought we are also going to reward it we are going to
reward everyone and we are also going to continue
giving gifts to all the clowns
while we walk we have prepared
gifts the friend your loot ready okay
one more recommendation I
only need clowns for  please why so
that the beginning of the parade is very beautiful
so that the clowns can grab the
banner please yes since they
are the most delicate ones who are going to
understand me faster
Majo please put
all the clowns here with Majo please  Please, yes,
come all the clowns who want to
help us.
Yes, there it is, or two, two,
I need more clowns, please,
guys, we're getting organized,
please, yes, outside we're going to give it to you.
We have the children who have come to
celebrate the Day of the initial occasion in the
park.  The wall we are going to greet them a
big applause for them because thanks
to the children we also owe ourselves
because if not there would be no job
very well we are going to organize ourselves I
need clowns please who
want to help us to carry the banner
forward they are going to take turns no  Don't
worry about the collaborators,
please come in ready,
the jurors are going to qualify within the
parade Yes please And right now we are going to
give out some tickets because we are going to have
raffles yes
Okay we are going to go I think we are already taking position
in order to be able to go out to take
our tour
People who have attended the pilgrimage are also arriving. So we
have to give it a little time
because
we will need some
and everyone is going to get together. We are going to the
door. I am going to have two collaborators there. Let's
get ready to leave. Please guys, let's get
ready to go out.  go out Please
hello hello hello hello hello we
're getting her ready to go out Please
the clowns
come come we
're getting ready to go out welcome
Thank you very much
[Music]
perfect [
Music]
collaborators please collaborators
[Music]
Hello hello hello A backpack has been lost
quickly please  collaborators
please
lead them clowns that I perform
only clowns entertainers characters and
children
[Applause]
[Music]
I lost my heart and prayer
[Applause] [
Music]
forward forward
[Music]
please we are approaching now to form
the line
and to everyone
row of four row of four
to the clown brothers who are arriving
to those who are arriving please
and the one of four
is already there continue please back back
move forward then take the photo please
outside we will take all the photos you
want
Hello  hello
papaya please
[Music]
guys get in line
and where is the buoy for the Peruvian clown
guys
are recording we're leaving
run over
[Music]
university student [
Music]
[Applause] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Music]
mate
[  Applause]
we move forward slowly
[Music]
this way we open here we take you
to enjoy our day
guys
happy day to all the clowns
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
Where are the clowns
[Music] Thank you
very much thank you very much
[Music]
documents signal ballots
do not use One lane of Avenida bench
Hallelujah
we are moving forward Welcome
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music]
shut up shut up shut up shut
up
there is a prize
Throw yourself a ladle [Music
] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
favorite
[Music] [
Music]
Hello happy Peruvian clown day Hello
How are you 25 of
majority
la mascarita la mascarita
zo
because we are clowns from the heart from the
heart from the heart
I am from the heart  from the heart from the heart
clown from the heart from the heart from the heart
the chicharrón your chicharrón
to the right
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Music]
[Music]
save your  cell phone please is
pending
[Music]
Greetings to Bautista
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [
[Music]
arriving to
attack Villa Salvador Villa María the
people of peace obviously people
continue coming to this beautiful Of course we are going
for being expelled we are in another
Felipe
a greeting to the clowns
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
to support our day please
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Hello everyone How are you
welcome  Hello how are you
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
the Peruvian clown
Hello piura
[Music] we have
n't arrived we arrived
Oh how are you
Chile Chile Chile Chile Chile Chile Chile
Chile Chile
the pretty one
here there are also girls Greetings and
girls
[Music]
[Music  ]
the stock market
[Music]
[Applause]
left left
Peruvian clown day
today in the center of Lima May 25
[Music]
please